The Sixth Sense was directed and written
by M night Shyamalan starring Bruce
Willis and Haley Joel Osment it was a
humongous phenomenon in 1999 I vividly
remember in school people going around
going hey Chris I was like yeah you're
quoting the movie good job
very original did you write that one oh
you're quoting the movie but seriously
in 1999 two humongous thrillers were
these big hits The Blair Witch Project
and The Sixth Sense
they had a huge impact on popular
culture everyone thought the Blair Witch
Project could possibly be real there was
a kid in my school who was like hey man
my friends and I snuck into the Blair
Witch Project just to see how many times
they said fuck and I was like how many
times did they say it oh like a hundred
and thirty times or something it was
crazy and it was also the same year
everyone was swinging their lightsabers
around talking about Jar Jar Binks as
well as going whoa I'm the one 1999 was
a crazy year in cinema lots of crazy pop
culture stuff happening all over the
place but everyone knew the Phantom
Menace was gonna be a hit The Matrix was
a big sci-fi action movie The Sixth
Sense came out of nowhere it was
directed by a no-name guy who's only two
films were wide awake he had written
Stuart Little and a small film called
praying with anger that was at a few
film festivals once but this unknown guy
to make a movie with Bruce Willis that
was such a phenomenon have all these
Oscar nominations and a script that was
sold for like a million bucks or
something it's unheard of now we all
know what eventually happened with M
night Shyamalan named it's kind of been
driven into the mud a bit with some of
his more recent films I've met the man
personally I actually had a chance to
meet him at Comic Con this year I went
to his panel for the movie the visit I
got to ask him a question I got to chat
with him and afterwards I was able to
shake his hand and talk to him a little
bit nice guy honestly a really nice guy
he gets a lot of hate but super nice guy
in real life The Sixth Sense though was
what really catapulted him to fame and
we're gonna be talking about that as the
first film in my M night Shyamalan
series leading up to the visit his film
that comes out this September I'm not
gonna review all of his movies for one
I've reviewed some of his movies already
but I am gonna talk about a few of his
films particularly his earlier ones
because those are really the ones
to examine and just as a warning if you
haven't seen this film this review is
gonna be filled with spoilers so go
watch the movie first and then comeback
this movie tells a tale of a child
psychiatrist played by Bruce Willis
who's trying to help a young boy played
by Haley Joel Osment who has the
affliction of seeing dead people walking
around in his home at school while he
walks around outside everywhere and he
is tortured by this and Willis's
character is trying to help him because
he feels that in some way this will
write a wrong of his past this is a
gorgeously directed movie with ingenious
writing I mean almost every shot has
something special about it or something
unique that's something that Shyamalan
brought to the horror genre because when
you watch the trailers for this movie
you actually go back and watch the
trailer it sells it as this straight-up
like teenage horror movie with Bruce
Willis in it but it's actually a movie
with very mature exploration of faith
and humanity and love and romance and
marriage and the things that can really
haunt a person not just ghosts but
things in your past being afraid that
late in life you might realize there's
that one thing you never got to do this
movie really dives deep into what makes
us human it's not just a scary ghost
movie those aspects of the film aren't
great the scary stuff is all really cool
but it's a movie that went so much more
under the surface in what you'd expect
and my god I cannot do a review of the
sixth sense without mentioning how great
Haley Joel Osment was in this movie it's
one of the best child performances of
all time I watched this movie yesterday
you know I always rewatch a film if I'm
gonna do a classic review an older
review I always want to watch the movie
to make sure it's fresh in my mind
I rewatched this movie and that kid is
gold he got an Oscar nomination for this
movie and he is still really good
despite endless parodies of the sixth
sense you can actually watch this movie
and be like this is a damn fuckin good
movie it is just so well directed and
since this is a spoiler review I'll just
talk about this Knight used the color
red brilliantly in this movie as a way
to depict something that dead have
interacted with something that's close
by to the dead the kids sweater the
woman who's poisoning her daughter she's
wearing red next to the red roses the
red doorknob red stairs the red balloon
the color scheme of this movie is
beautiful they even went around in two
scenes and maybe if there was
accidentally a little Rand
read somewhere they'd removed that read
from the scene so that it would retain
its significance whenever they wanted to
use it one of my favorite scenes in the
movie is when Malcolm played by Willis
is trying to get Cole played by Ozma
to come into the room and sit down so we
can talk with him he plays this mental
game with him where if he gets something
right about Coley has to take a step
closer the direction of the scene and
the way it's written and Willis is
really funny just little comedic senses
where he's like holding his face and
making little noises it's so great I've
never seen Willis do a movie like this
and this up until then in my opinion was
the best performance he'd ever pulled
off he was so great in the sixth sense
and it was something that I wasn't used
to seeing because yeah he was good in
die hard he was good in Pulp Fiction but
this was a very subtle and quiet role
and he pulled it off like it was written
for him in fact it was written for him
Shyamalan specifically wrote that role
for Willis he took it and he was
actually one of the guys who really
championed Shaw Milan back in the day
when other people were like now you
don't get to do this you don't get to do
that Willis according to Shyamalan
anyway was someone who was always on his
side supporting him which is really cool
I think now before we get the famous
scene where Cole says I see dead people
and all that's revealed the movie has a
great way of hinting at these strange
little things you don't always know what
he's so afraid of you don't quite know
what's going on if you didn't see the
trailers or don't know the plot once
they finally revealed this and the
camera is slowly panning in on Willis
and he's trying to get Cole to explain
it more the camerawork in this scene is
perfect it's perfect
ivory watched the scene a couple times
just in the past day because it is a
perfectly directed moment and as soon as
that reveal happens they just have funs
at Cole's at home weird people are
walking through his house we get to see
what he's seeing and it was great like
as a filmmaker or a writer once you now
have that out in the open you can just
have fun with it and play with it and I
can see Shyamalan really doing that
after that reveal finally hits the fan
but he always maintains a great sense of
what the film is actually about regret
remorse sorrow pain loss things that are
sad and deep and emotional not just
scary horror music with jump scares this
movie was a lot more than that and I got
to talk about Toni Collette as Cole's
mother she gives such a real performance
when I watch her I'm
not thinking it's an actress 100% I know
toni collette I've seen her in a lot of
movies she's always really good when I
watch her in this movie she is that
character she perfectly embodied this
character this single mother who's
struggling with the pain of not
understanding what is torturing her
child and there's a little moment in the
scene I never noticed until last night
when I rewatched it when Malcolm is
watching his wife and she's embracing
this guy in her store
he throws something at the window or he
kicks the window we don't know when it
pans back to him walking away he appears
to be holding the place where he got
shot in the opening scene never noticed
that ever ever it's such a great little
character moment I love it now
eventually Willis starts to think about
what really is going on with Cole and he
has this idea that these ghosts are just
trying to communicate to Cole because
they need help with something some kind
of unfinished business something that
needs to be solved this leads us to this
truly horrifying when you really think
about it scene in which a father
discovers that his wife was keeping
their now dead daughter sick and that is
just that's scarier than any jump scare
just the thought of that the thought of
being around all these people at this
funeral who are watching this happen
watching this knowledge come to fruition
this father seeing this it's fucking
terrifying
that's horror that's what horror movies
nowadays have forgotten about actual
horror something that could actually
happen it's terrifying and sad and
disturbing
that's horror now as I mentioned Toni
Collette is trying to figure out what's
wrong with her son throughout the entire
film once these characters finally have
their arc when they're stuck in traffic
and Cole admits to her that he can see
dead people and they have this beautiful
moment where he tells his mother about
his grandmother her mother and the
things that she wanted to say oh my god
it's just tears it's so beautiful it's
such a great moment the way all the
characters in this movie reached their
arcs at just the right little moments
it's such a smart script so we get to
the big twist more than likely you know
what it is Bruce Willis has been dead
the entire time he's actually a ghost
it's probably the most famous twist in
movie history because it is a great
twist it's not just a shocking ending it
makes sense when you re watch the entire
film it makes the second viewing better
because you can actually go back in your
life
oh my god every scene still works when
he's dead when coal is saying directly
to Malcolm's face I see dead people
they don't know they're dead they're
walking around like regular people it's
just panning in on Bruce Willis's face
like here you go this is it
and most audience members were just like
this is a really good movie yeah he's
dead you see certain scenes and in your
head you had assumed while he was
talking to Tony Collette
that's why it cut to a wide of them in
the same room together but no he really
wasn't he was just sitting there she was
waiting for her son to come home you see
the scene where he's sitting next to his
wife at the anniversary dinner and you
realized when he sat in the chair the
chair didn't even move he didn't
interact with anything in that scene
nothing would have been floating or
moving and everyone's like freaking out
because the chairs like just pushed
itself back he interacted with nothing
in that scene but our eyes told us that
something was happening because we're so
used to seeing movies played in a
certain way so not only is it a very
clever twist ending but it changes the
entire film for the better makes you
realize that they were playing with the
wave films are edited and our eyes told
us that certain things were happening
that weren't I'm talking genius level
writing and directing here Shyamalan The
Sixth Sense most definitely gets an A+
so leading up to the visit I want to
talk some more about some Shyamalan
films over this next month and my next
review is gonna be for a Shyamalan film
I have never reviewed and that is
unbreakable I'm very excited to talk to
you guys about that film look forward to
that very soon and as always thank you
so much for watching guys and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck my nice
[Music]
[Applause]